we are pleased to have in our studio
Louie witcha tell our economics writer
of the New York Times he has just
published a book the disposable American
and this book is going to be the main
subject of our conversation this morning
so witcha tell welcome thank you very
much for inviting me now first of all
the subject of your book is of course of
great topical importance given these
data layoffs kind of consequences but if
you tell us a little bit how did you
come up with the idea of writing this
book well I've been covering economics
for the times since the late 80s and it
was almost every other story in one form
or another had to do with this process
of layoffs and I sort of tracked it we
resisted them quite a bit in the early
80s late 70s early 80s and that
resistance gradually evaporated when you
said they just admitting who existed we
as a people when there was a there was a
visit people would protest the layoffs
people would when when it spread to
white-collar workers for example to the
harvard class of 58 as it though and
they realized that some of their own
people were laid off in the early night
it was great shock there was great
effort to try to help them get back into
their jobs when some of the steel mill
shut down there was an effort on the
part of a community to a campbell works
in near youngstown ohio to get it to the
community to take it over put it back on
its feet President Carter came in at
that time with a with a loan to help
modernize the loan guarantee to help
modernize the mill so that it could be
globally competitive that sort of
reaction that desire to save industry
and jobs gradually dissipated so which
is what i mean by acquiescence and we
got to the point where you laid off
5,000 workers which was headlines across
the country in the late 70s it's barely
gets into the paper now and we and we've
come to accept that we forgot the
resistance we forgot the context we've
lost sight of the fact that there
are alternatives not if not to all the
layers into a lot of them before we go
into the question of layoffs let's first
of all here what are the conditions in
the 70s or 60s that allowed the American
workers a kind of job security that they
don't have anymore well the job security
in America which is a very unique
American thing was quite practical
started in the late 1800s with the rise
of giant corporations the first of the
Industrial Revolution what later became
multinationals Procter and Gamble dupont
Eastman Kodak the giant railroads Alfred
Chandler at Harvard is a wonderful
historian it became quite managers
realized that job security was important
these were complex organizations they
needed experienced people to run them
and so they put into place policies the
managers themselves that preserve the
jobs part of it was also Union agitation
Procter and Gamble came up with a very
william proctor came up with a very
innovative pension plan in 1888 which
happened to be a year after the
Haymarket riots in chicago and so he was
worried about unrest but he was worried
about losing workers he needed skilled
people this one on right up to the 30s
what they called it welfare capitalism
in the 30s of course it began to
dissipate but we stepped in of course
during that huge depression with laws
labor laws that strengthen it and after
the war it was sent with a memory of the
depression and the job loss and the and
the importance of job security even
Peter Drucker recognized in one of his
best management books everybody was in
favor of job security and that's animal
enabled not only productivity but
company sort of doing well they did well
in productivity Rose your workers and of
course we had hegemony and we we were no
one was competing against us well Along
Came of course the global competition in
the form of autos from Japan and hand
tools which I illustrate in a chapter
about the Stanley alerts from Asia and
all sorts of products we lost
are our monopoly if you will and we were
caught at a moment when we weren't so
efficient in manufacturing and there was
a need to cut labor costs and to do a
number of things but what started out as
a legitimate response to global
competition went in my opinion or in my
reporting in all my reporting and this
is what what drove me to write this book
beyond what you could justify with
global competition or even good sense so
what so the phone you are writing your
book that the corporations basically
look at mass layoffs as the only
cost-cutting measure they could adapt in
order to adjust to the competition how
did they get I'm doing this well it's
very interesting it's not just mass
layoffs it's all sorts of layers and
part of this of course was they were
going through a period when unions were
in decline the unions were strongest in
the company's most exposed to and to
global competition and there was an
undercurrent of resistance to unions
that developed in the 80s part of it
brought on by the unions themselves so
and we also got the we got into the idea
which was a myth that look were not
efficient but if you'll just bear with
us folks and bear bear the way the pain
of losing your job in a few years will
become efficient and the layoffs will
stop and we'll reach a new equilibrium
the I think what what developed was that
labor cost cutting in the form of
layoffs became the root of least
resistance and a form of capitalizing on
financial on profits on profitability in
on the stock market which became the
single measure rather than in the past
when CEOs were they had the stock cheryl
is to worry about but also the workers
and the community and the suppliers and
the customers and and the society as a
whole so this was a kind of
I'm shift is a paradigm shift it sums up
the company shareholders and directors
caring not about workers but caring only
about the quarterly bottom line yes and
so how did this happen this is the kind
of mystery it is it's still a mystery to
me as much as I've explained it but the
paradigm shift included going from a
society in which we thought of ourselves
as a community if you will everyone in
it for everyone else to this
individualism which has always been a
strain in American society which got out
of hand I think that it became very
convenient to blame workers for their
own layoffs we get to the point where we
said look we have to lay you off because
you're not worth what we're paying you
tremendous psychologically damaging blow
to people and then we said the solution
is training and education and you'll
qualify for the good jobs out there
there weren't enough good jobs out there
so you blamed again for not enough
training not moving around not being
flexible enough very convenient for the
Republicans and the Democrats they
didn't have to come up with policies
that might challenge the layoffs and
challenge what was going on very
convenient of course for the CEOs they
were absolved of responsibility but we
did not measure the social damage we
used to measure in this country all
sorts of social damage and we didn't
measure for example the damage to the
psychological damage from being told
that you don't have value I I was amazed
doing this story at the extended doing
this book you know a journalist does it
goes out and interview somebody first
daily story or for a story that's done
after a month research and you don't get
deeply into the lives of these people
until you do a book and then you really
become involved tracking families and I
only use in the book some of the people
that I've got to know over the years you
realize that I
never thought I would be so drawn into
the psychiatric aspects of layoffs I'm
not talking unemployment unemployment is
a separate issue just this traumatic
statement that you don't have a place in
society in the workplace in a society
that where people's identity is very
much wrapped up in the workplace among
other forms of identity family community
and so forth the workplace is very
important so here you're doing this
damage and I went to psychiatry they
said yes this is a real we're
undermining we run across that all the
time in therapy and we are undermining
public health in fact I'm going to go
and make this point to a psychiatric
convention in less than a month and and
we're not putting a warning label on it
there's something wrong well if we have
to measure that if we're not going to
measure that then we're not going to put
some sort of breaks on layoffs again I
do not want to say that we can stop the
layoffs but I do think that if we
measured them we the damage we would
begin to say well is there a weighted to
lay off five people instead of 10 are
there ways to make people feel better if
we lay them off their social ways to
deal with this problem one of the things
that I found most interesting in your
book is the fact that Democrats starting
with jimmy carter's seem to have adapted
policies which have legitimized the
layoffs that had begun in large scale
how did this happen why did the carter
administration go along with this well
the Carter Administration they got into
deregulation which was becoming quite a
public pressure at the time that was one
thing the deregulation of the airlines
and there was at one point thirteen
percent of the workforce was protected
by worked in regulated industries and
regulation meant job protection that's
not the same regulation as good or
shouldn't be altered but a protection
was removed carter also became more
concerned with inflation than he did
with full employment if you will and he
became can
cerned that he was that the United
States had to be the buyer of last
resort for the rest of the world it
entered into his decision not to go
through with this loan guarantee to
improve to upgrade the technology at the
Campbell works why europeans were
governments were helping their steel
industry rebuild carter felt it was
important to purchase European steel and
so we it wasn't that them so much that
the Japanese invaded our markets but to
some extent we invited them in we were
and I can't criticize that necessarily
that was the nature of globalization
what I do criticize is that we then
turned around and in the name of
globalization we got into layoffs saying
we need this for to compete globally
when in fact so far as I can tell from
all my research layoffs and outsourcing
are 90 or 70 or 80 or 60 percent a
domestic affair not another there aren't
that many jobs yet rising that have gone
off shore yeah I will come to that but
let me dig this point you mentioned on
page 14 the by the late 90s however the
middle America sentiment had dissipated
Americans had become focused on quality
and price and uninterested in origin yes
that a product was made abroad ceased to
be a negative now is it realistic to
think that people consumers in peacetime
would pay more attention to a patriotic
concern of made in America than about
quality and price well I was just trying
to make the point that one of the
resistances to layoffs was this idea
that made in America was important it
was part of our national wealth if you
will it wasn't it wasn't a peace or war
issue as much as it was and it wasn't
logical they were but it was an issue of
support our workers so I bought a ford
taurus once was the last American car i
bought it was so
I edited I since purchased at Nissan but
there was a label right on the front
window saying made in America by
American labor and Walmart made a big
big
advertising campaign about of how they
purchased only american-made goods until
CBS or one of the networks came along
and just went shopping in this store and
found that most of it was made abroad
well walmart doesn't even think about a
thing like that anymore so the and so on
the margin chipping away jobs were lost
I'm not going to say they were lost for
a bad reason but there was that
resistance that sense of certain things
should stay home right dissipated other
factor you mentioned among many things
that have allowed this lay off to
continue is on page 135 you caught a
business historian Peter Cappelli he's
saying that there had always been the
issue of balancing corporate
profitability with protections for
employees and own communities the
shareholder value movement altered the
balance yes now how do you make
shareholders care more about employees
and community than about their portfolio
value well it wasn't it you can't get
shareholders to do that but the out of
the depression and out of the early is
the rise of job security in the early
before the depression came this sense of
we didn't want to go through those sort
of traumas again came a constituency for
job security and came a constituency for
community protection the corporate
culture it was a culture and I
Illustrated it with the Stanley works
there were three chief executives three
generations of chief executives they
thought that way they would have loved
to have beaten down labor but it wasn't
socially acceptable unions had enough
power to push back so the issues were
never over layoffs they were always over
furloughs or seniority who might be sent
home for six weeks but until business
picked up again and that was a culture
and somehow is starting with Carter the
importance of capital
the decline of unions sharehold the rise
of options and a financial instruments
the use of stock and of bonuses to pace
chief executives and the attachment of
CEO pay to performance which was never
is emphasized in the past as it is today
we shifted to a shareholder oriented
society kidding ourselves and that we
used to talk about this all the time we
stopped doing it we're all shareholders
so if we're not getting a salary well we
can live off our dividends nobody says
that anymore but that was actually a
thought at one time and it really went
strongly when it was blue-collar workers
because we all could say other they're
not worth what we paid him then it's
shifted to white-collar workers like
ourselves and we didn't want to say that
anymore and there was a backlash in the
90s and so there was a political moment
when Bill Clinton running for a second
term could have pushed back and he said
in effect I don't want class warfare
fair that was a phrase that one of his
people used if not himself the opposing
class being the CEOs so he took a
position that he would generate enough
jobs people could get laid off they
would get it re educated and retrained
and segue into jobs that paid as well as
the ones they lost well that didn't
happen but that was sort of when he took
that position maybe the last barrier to
layoffs came down mm-hmm you say that
when NAFTA was signed yes there was a
promise that Odelle maybe or 10 to 10
years that we net gain up to hun at
other jobs but after 10 years the up to
quarter three quarter of a million to a
million job have been lost years now can
you actually clearly linked this job
loss to NAFTA I can't and of course
that's a huge debate the standard is
that we went from a surplus a surplus in
our trade at the
nafta to a deficit and then the it's
been several books written about it and
is afl-cio and and various think tanks
in Washington have argued what the
number is but I think everyone agrees
that jobs have been lost perhaps not as
many as some quarters would suggest but
that there has been a job loss the
original idea that we would generate
jobs by shipping capital goods to Mexico
for use in producing consumer goods
didn't quite work out that way in fact
jobs little moved from Mexico to China
yes jobs invite moved from Mexico to
China we this was just the beginning and
you can't just say so in the end it was
NAFTA shifted jobs overseas but I would
still argue even with NAFTA not to
became a turning point for mr. clinton i
would say during his first term he took
a few steps to try to stem the layoffs
he tried for example to get rid to
declare illegal the use of replacement
workers permanent replacements for
strikers he tried to make unemployment
insurance premiums foreign corporations
higher so that might be nothing but the
Congress didn't puzzles nothing and when
96 came along and Pat Buchanan did well
in the New Hampshire primary and there
was this backlash and the New York Times
was writing a downsizing series of which
I was part and Alan Sloan in Newsweek
was talking about corporate killers his
response was to soothe everyone and say
we'll do it through job creation so and
so that was a big that was sort of a
will live with layoffs from now on and
we didn't properly measure the layoffs
we don't know even now we don't measure
the extent of them so it he himself
argued they're not as bad as you
journalists are saying they are only now
are the statistics beginning to catch up
and even then they don't catch the
hidden layoffs the forced retirement but
you give the number from the US bureau
of labor statistics the 30 million jobs
manufacturing they've lost in those just
jobs
I see but I did that after many
conversations with tom nardone who's in
charge of all this data and I've known
people at the BLS a wonderful agency for
a long time that 30 million is my figure
what you can deduct from the worker
displacement the biennial worker
displacement survey in which people are
asked whether they had lost the job for
because it was abolished or four very
minute for very restricted reasons you
could come up full time workers this is
an unpublished statistic about 100
million full-time workers in America
today maybe four percent are laid off
annually according to that survey then
and this is my estimate if you added in
all the people I mean layoffs are
shifted to a different to a more
indirect form who accept a retirement
package knowing that if they didn't they
would have a problem or quit because
they don't want to take a cut in pay or
I take a buyout thinking that if they
don't they might be forced out of the
company without one all these hidden
forms of layoffs you come up with about
seven percent roughly of all full-time
workers nevermind point on what period
annually I'm gonna ask ya and that's a
lot and that would if we had that sort
of data people might get alarmed because
I think I didn't think of this one I was
writing the book but I think that the
main solution quote unquote that I offer
is to inform people of what has gone on
starting in the late 19th century and
when they get a sense of what's happened
what they've forgotten maybe a
discussion will start and maybe people
will say do we have to do all this and
and that in the end has to be the
solution yeah well i'll come back to the
solution just one question in your whole
book i couldn't find the word
globalization once that's true and yet
it seems to me that the book illustrates
want the impacts of globalization on
american economy the examples you gave
up companies downsizing late
they're all doing because they're facing
competition from abroad so if you are to
apportion kind of responsibility for
America's layoffs what percentage of
responsibility will put on global
trading challenge as opposed to
corporate policy as government policies
or maybe you and I would disagree on
this but i would put less of an emphasis
on globalization and i would on
corporate policies they both of course
play a role i'm not going to even begin
to suggest that we should keep the shoe
industry or the textile industry in
America or other labor intensive
industries but there are cases where on
the margin and the margin is where the
solution is we go into far the stanley
works for example makes tape measures
now Stanley works is a company that
produced tool hand tools and tool so
Stanley works is based in New Britain
Connecticut and produces hand tools one
of its most famous is this tape measure
that spools out of it out of a cassette
that you hooked to your belt they once
made all the domestic supply in the
United States they made an effort and I
was just talking to the CEO the other
day who was in this book Richard heirs
to automate their main plant in New
Britain and they did automate they
automated badly and they should have
gone back at it again and they still
keep a certain amount of the production
here but they had put a plant in
Thailand and where they intended
originally to make these tape measures
for the foreign market they then decided
the third CEO who came in the heck with
that will make him and ship him back to
the United States a lot of them and that
will put a lot of pressure on labor in
our plants that remain in America I
would question whether that was
necessary or whether a lot of that tape
measure production could have been kept
here with automation that's not the same
thing as keeping the workers because the
automation might have cost the
jobs anyway but there would have been
the production here the spin-off
industries and a sense that we're trying
to keep people here so that with other
policies of helping people might have at
least taken some of the stigma out of
layoffs I have another example of the
United Airlines maintenance center in
Indianapolis there was a it was a
brilliantly executed maintenance center
probably one of the finest in the world
for narrow body jets that is the 737 the
a319s and so forth a they could put a
and it was built in the early 90s and
for a while until a labor dispute
erupted and before 2001 they were doing
the FAA requires that these jetspeed
stripped down dismantled and rebuilt
every five years they were doing that in
10 days or 11 days instead of 20 days it
was so and then that extra revenue from
the extra time in the air paid the
relatively high wages of the mechanics
and of the operation of the center it
was so efficient that Lufthansa was
thinking about bringing globalization
here its planes here it was a winner in
the global battlefield well this labor
dispute developed far be it from the all
sides were at fault as far as I could
see and 911 just complicated the matter
what eventually there was a slowdown
United dealt with it by outsourcing this
was before nine eleven and and it
continued to outsource and it eventually
shut down that center now because it was
a source to some other place in the
United States in the United States might
someday that outsourcing might go
overseas but so far it's in the south
and the United States well 20 or 30
years ago and this was with the even
though they didn't even own the center
the Indianapolis government did Indiana
and Indianapolis government 20 or 30
years ago outsourcing didn't exist the
company would have been forced to make
some agreement with labor and layoffs
would have been socially unacceptable
for an air
or more so than they are today and so
there would have been an agreement of
some sort labor in fact was trying after
being cantankerous and difficult scene
difficult seeing what was happening the
unions were trying to we're giving in
right and left the company said the heck
with it we're just not going to expose
ourselves to this sort of trouble again
and I'm oversimplifying the story but
and when I asked them about it they said
it was we sure the efficiency pays off
but so does really cheap labor down
south so the irony was that some of
these mechanics who got laid off in in
Indianapolis at earning thirty dollars
an hour are now it went to work at some
of the out sources for seventeen dollars
an hour and that is no level Union there
in the south you know even are some
labor unions the labor unions put up
with that that labor unions are no
longer a barrier to seventeen dollars an
hour and so you you then you've lost
that Center is virtually not operating
it's got some of the phaser rented out
and so you've lost this jewel there's a
lot of mechanics some of them ended up
right one of them I tracked for a while
ended up running a water taxi to running
trucks and driving trucks all this
wonderful talent and skill lost wasted
not to mention the psychological damage
so in that sense it's not gold it is
globalization but it's not globalization
if there was a policy yeah it's a policy
thing and it's a it's if you want to
talk globalization we could have won
that battle and all I can't give you a
silver bullet over-riding solution but
if you take a case by case and say look
folks globalization is a factor and we
are losing jobs to globalization and it
does make it a lot easier to undercut
unions here but we will try as a people
to limit the damage and that's about all
you can do in this day and age in your
book you have basically talked about
blue collar workers yes now and white
collar collar workers in one chef right
the white color of jobs are now more at
risk
outsourcing because of the electronic
highway that detects child away have you
looked at that aspect of well as a
reporter and there is a footnote in this
book so far the most and and I've been
over this with a number of people who
try to collect these figures and there
it's very hard to find but so far
there's probably fewer than a million
jobs that have been lost to this sort of
offshoring it's not a big number yet
most of the white collar work is being
lost right here in America as a means of
cost-cutting and I auto mission and
automation right and and just simply we
don't want to bear this cost and indium
that's partly an indirect result of the
of the competition from abroad but in
the auto industry Toyota and Honda are
paying wages almost as good as what is
what a lot of UAW workers are earning
they don't have the legacy costs for
health care and they're doing quite
quite you know it's not so much a wage
issue in a lot of industries as it is a
behavioral issue so what I have to sort
out every time globalization comes up
what is truly global competition and
what is something here now you go to
whirlpool this isn't in the book but I
and they say look we've set up we have
lots of factories in America but we also
make our microwaves in in China because
we want a global platform there and we
make high-end front loading washing
machines in Germany and we're going to
make lower end front loading washing
machines in Mexico because we don't want
to concentrate too much in this country
we want a global platform well that's
fine for Whirlpool it's a fun wonderful
country but there has to be some
recognition of what are the National
needs of a nation and what are the
corporate needs and we've lost that
debate yeah coming back coming to your
solutions chapter here if you could sum
up the main points what are the
resolutions were well if I could have
written this book without a solutions
chapter I would have been very happy
I'm in a my main solution is to make
people aware of what's happening to them
and one of the chapters I dealt with
made the point that companies that
engage in layoffs often don't do as well
on the stock market or in profits as
companies that do engage in layoffs of
in fact there's there's a lot of
evidence that for jobseekers invent
they're cutting costs in vain yeah I
mean harley-davidson for example had
this terrible situation where back in
the 80s they were saved only because
reagan put import quotas on motorcycles
and they reorganized and they got back
into business and then they made a deal
with their unions that they would every
time there was an issue the unions would
have a chance the pass judgment on it
was in debate and I went out there once
and did a story about them and you can
get it you could sit for an hour and a
half and listen to the union's complain
about how they're always getting the
losing end of every of every
cost-cutting deal but the but the truth
of the matter is that over the last
decade almost no one has been laid off
at that company there have been
compromises of all sorts that have been
made so my solutions are first of all
count the house right and there are
people like Henry Farber and others who
would like to have a survey of displaced
workers Henry Farber's of Princeton
University labor economist is quite
expert in this area and others a survey
that captures the hidden layoffs because
these are no longer the old-style
blue-collar you know factory type of
Wales the forced retirement and so forth
that had so many white collar workers
that would be very important because we
would then have a better statistical
sense of what's happening to ourselves I
also think it would be a good idea if we
made if we required what amounts to
environmental impact statements for
companies except in this case it would
be every company every year listing all
the people who depart from the company
and how they departed
quit retired laid off whatever the
reasons and then academics such as
yourself would would put together a
database and if the average layoffs for
the affair of the airline industry was a
hundred a month and here's an airline
with 125 you'd say well why hundred and
twenty-five well how come the average in
a global economy is a hundred why are
you beyond the average that would have
an inhibiting effect it certainly would
be a source of debate so shimming by
statistics ashaming by statistics would
be a wonderful start to this debate I
also raise and I do please I don't have
a solution for this but it's part of the
debate and it's been in the debate in
America for a long time and there's the
question of whether the private sector
by itself with the best will in the
world can generate enough jobs good jobs
a decent pay to meet the demand for them
and so far that is not happening so this
issue came up in the debate over the
employment act of 1940 61 it was really
concern about another depression and
whether the government should become the
employer of last resort it was we're not
a nation that goes easily to a sort of
public investment and as a source of
economic activity and I'm not talking
Keynesian stimulus I'm talking and then
it came up again in the in the mid-70s
during the severe recession the start of
the debate of first dress for the
humphrey-hawkins act of 78 augustus
hawkins a black congressman from watts
which had the endless unemployment
wanted to right into the act and did
right into the early dress of the act
and making the government the employer
of last resort the source of of jobs
good jobs if and when the private sector
couldn't do it well humphrey might have
picked up that idea but he he died of
cancer and Carter came in and Carter
wasn't interested Carter was more
concerned about inflation and about but
a [ __ ] nemesis indeed try one stage to
put some money in
Mike and chip design yes there was a
semitech and you know so there were a
number i remember well this is another
reason i wrote the book one of my early
stories was the SEMATECH effort where
companies came together to put money
into chip design to become but it did
and it didn't pan out it worked for a
while there was federal money it was
very controversial and that barrier to
lay off so to speak came down and I was
a joke Bowers at Harvard Business School
is one of the big forces behind that it
there was big conferences about it you
can't you have to go back to the into
the archives to even find out about it
now yeah there were all these possible
ways to throw sand into the job loss you
know it's a delayed and in that process
of d'Alene that sense of the country
trying to preserve things I think is a
healthy thing he also mentioned one of
the solutions that the workers right to
organize in other countries should be
part of it trade negotiation that has
been tried as you know that Clinton
actually raised that during the Seattle
meeting and it was you know got a huge
thumbs down for all the judges now is it
realistic that countries which are just
coming out of not becoming independent
or really developing countries to have
the same labor standard as the developed
countries I don't think so but yeah what
I what frightens me is that developed
countries are this country at least has
lowered its labor standard rather than
try trying to push at the labor
standards of other countries Clinton did
not except for the Jordanian trini trade
agreement has not did not write into his
agreements labor standards or
environmental standards so in a sense we
aren't engaged in free trade if you
think of lower standards as a form of
barrier
Intel's president at one points and I
think I quote him in my book the layoffs
and their consequences in disposable
American they said look why should I put
a factory in America when I can go to
some other country I think he was
thinking of Ireland and save a billion
dollars on taxes well he's why should he
but so there should be trade agreements
that in one form or another neutralized
taxes otherwise it's not free trade the
the tax breaks become a form of tariff
if you will so I mean these are all
issues that should be back on the table
all the time and if they were we might
be no better off than we are today but I
think spiritually or we would we would
go from a sense of not even trying to
preserve people of throwing people away
and telling them it's their own fault
which is the biggest point I have to
make in this book to say no you're
valuable we don't know if we can
actually save your job but we're going
to try so making people aware of the
problem is the is the first step and
who's you have taken and thank you very
much for your book and for coming to our
studio I thank you for asking me and
thanking you thank you for your
questions thank you